-♪ Hey, hey, hey, robot ♪
♪ Hey, robot ♪
-Now, I'm gonna need some help.
So joining me now is the star
of the new Hulu show
"Nine Perfect Strangers."
Please welcome Melissa McCarthy!
What are you talking about? Yes!
That's what I'm talking about!
-Hey!
-Hi, bud.
-When you think
of technology and robots,
you think of me, right?
-Yeah, exactly correct.
Yeah, now, I think
this is going to be perfect,
'cause here's why
I did think about you.
Because this is based on a real
board game called "Hey Robot"
that you can play at home.
It's like the classic game
"Password"
but your partner
is a smart speaker.
First, I'll pick a card
with a word on it.
Then we'll take turns
asking a question
to get the speaker to say that
word somewhere in its answer.
If it does, you get a point.
And, Melissa, the reason
why I did think of you --
because you're actually
one of the new voices of Alexa.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's true,
which is super creepy
in my house.
My kids, I think,
are very rattled by it.
And Ben likes to talk
to it a lot. But, yeah,
I guess they really needed,
like, a nasal Chicago voice.
-[ Laughs ] Well, they got --
This just must be --
It's amazing.
Alright, well, so, instead of
Alexa, we're going to use --
We're gonna be
asking you instead.
Well, not you. But we'll ask
the Alexa you, okay?
-Great.
-Alright. I will go first.
Here we go.
-Okay.
-Alright, I have to
get it to say chameleon.
I guess I'm not hiding that
from this.
Alright, ready? I have to get it
to say that. Okay.
Hey, Melissa, what are the three
biggest hits of Culture Club?
-Here's something
I found on the Web.
According to access.com,
between late '83 and early 1984,
Culture Club was the biggest
band in new wave
as "Color by Numbers"
spawned two more smash hits,
and "Miss me Blind," #5 Hot 100,
and "It's a Miracle," #4 U.K.,
#13, Hot 100.
-Yeah, okay.
What?!
[ Buzzer ]
"Miss Me Blind"? Okay.
You're laughing?
You think that's funny?
That was so bizarre
to hear your voice.
-"She's not gonna shut up."
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. They didn't get it.
Your chance to steal.
Can you get --
-Ooh.
-Can you get you get you
to say this word?
-Here's something creepy.
Hey, Melissa, what do you call
a lizard that changes color?
-Here's something I found
on the Web.
According to
walkhighlands.co.uk,
common lizard
is the more usual name,
but it retains its other moniker
via it's scientific name,
zootoca vivipara.
[ Laughter ]
-Ah.
[ Buzzer ]
Ah, see, if the word was --
-You know what's it's weird
is they don't give me
any of that stuff.
I just know it
off the top of my head, so...
-Wait, you know
"zacoca babaveba"?
Alright, we're going to move on.
That one -- Well, no one
gets a point for that one.
Melissa, it's your chance.
You're up.
You have to get you, your Alexa,
to say...
meditation.
-Hey, Melissa,
when you go to a spa retreat
and you sit quietly,
what is that called?
-I don't have an answer
for that.
[ Laughter ]
-Why don't you try --
Why don't you do it again?
No, do it again. Ask it again.
-Okay, ready.
Hey, Melissa,
can you say meditation?
[ Laughter ]
-The states of meditation...
[ Bell dinging ]
-Yeah, you got that one.
We got to clarify the rules.
-You didn't say
we couldn't cheat.
-That's not in the rules.
That's --
[ Soothing music playing ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-This feels good.
-This feels great.
This feels great.
This must be the most --
the most personal interview
we've ever had,
the deepest, by far.
Wow. Hey, Melissa, stop.
I didn't know you could do that.
Alright, Melissa,
this is it right here.
This -- It's 1-0,
and it's your turn
since you are our guest.
This is the final round.
This is worth 1,000 points
right here.
Can you get your version
of Alexa to say...
jerk?
-I don't know what year.
Hey, Alexa,
name a Steve Martin film
that also could be
considered an insult.
-Hmm, I don't know that.
[ Audience groans ]
-I was going to
go with that, as well.
Uh -- Uh --
-How about -- How about,
"Melissa, what was
Steve Martin's breakout film?"
-Tariq's playing now.
-I didn't know
we could ask for help.
-Yeah, yeah, I guess --
Hey, Melissa, what was
Steve Martin's breakout film?
-Steve Martin's first film
was "Father of the Bride."
-What?!
-That's not true!
[ Laughter ]
-Dude, what is --
That's not true.
Alright, I got one. I got one.
-That's not true.
-Here we go.
That is not correct at all.
[ Laughter ]
Hey --
-Shame on you, Melissa.
-Hey, Melissa, what's a popular
type of chicken in Jamaica?
[ Laughter ]
-Hmm, I'm just not sure.
Apologies.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Maybe you got to travel more.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, Melissa, name the comedians
that are famous for prank calls.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Here's something
I found on reference.com.
Celebrities who were famous
primarily for making
prank phone calls
include the Tube Bar Pranksters,
John Elmo and Jim Davidson,
and the Jerky Boys.
-Yes! That's right.
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?!
-Melissa McCarthy, everybody!